In the Westworld Season 3 finale, Caleb takes
Dolores’ brain, cause last episode, Dolores
was fried by an EMP.
The EMP now says “RESERVE POWER ON” – so
presumably all these ‘outlier’ people
are still safely frozen in stasis.
Which could be important – humanity now
faces “apocalypse”, and possibly “extinction”
, so they might need these hundreds of preserved
humans.
Dolores’ voice assistant guides Caleb to
a backup Dolores body at an Itaidoshin Distillery
– we previously saw the Singapore Itaishoshin
– the name means many bodies, one mind – so
Caleb plugs Dolores’ mind into a new body
.
Caleb demands some answers , so Dolores reveals
that she met Caleb years ago . When Caleb
joined the military, he was trained at a special
Delos park, where soldiers use hosts as “live
targets” – we see Dolores, Hanaryo, and
Craddock playing roles in this “Park 5”.
In the real world, militaries do use simulations
and games as training – so it’s believable
they’d use Westworld’s robots.
The Westworld website always showed six parks,
and now we've seen them all – there’s
Westworld, Shogunworld, Warworld, medieval
world, The Raj, and this military training
world.
In the park, there are sensors in Caleb’s
helmet.
Cause last season, we learned that the hats
in Westworld have brain scanners built in,
to record data on peoples’ minds.
That data is stored in the Forge , where Dolores
read books of peoples’ programming.
Dolores must have read Caleb’s book about
his mind – and that helped her predict and
control him this season . Like, it probably
wasn’t a coincidence that Dolores just happened
to fall into Caleb’s arms.
She took him on this whole journey of remembering
his past to manipulate him into fighting her
revolution . To some extent, Dolores was controlling
Caleb from the start.
But at the same time, Dolores chose Caleb
for his free will .
In Park 5, some soldiers wanted to use the
hosts for sex , but Caleb took a stand and
stopped them . So Dolores saw that Caleb could
lead humans to be better – to end the cycle
of violence and abuse that Dolores knew from
Westworld.
And this is why Dolores chose Caleb to lead
the revolution to free humanity.
Of course, ‘not being a rapst’ is a pretty..
low standard to make Caleb the hope for all
humanity.
But the point is that Caleb represents human
free will – the ability to change, and choose
. Last season said that humans can’t change,
have no free will, can only follow our code
– like how William is trapped in a cycle
of self-destruction.
Caleb is the opposite – he was trained to
be a killer, destined for suicide, and yet
he chooses empathy freedom and life.
Dolores says “Free will does exist” – “It's
just fcuking hard” .
The world breaks into “chaos” . Earlier,
Dolores leaked everyone’s Incite profiles,
revealing how they’re controlled by Rehoboam’s
algorithms – so in Los Angeles, protests
and riots break out – it’s a wild rebellion
for freedom, but it’s also controlled by
Dolores . She uses the Rico app to “Move”
the riots to certain places, she pays performance
bonuses to protesters . So ironically, she
uses tools of control to fight against a system
of control . Just like Dolores controls Caleb
to give him freedom.
And like Ford controlled Dolores and Maeve
to help free them.
Freedom and control are opposites, but control
can lead you to freedom – like, having to
go to school can get you opportunities later.
And freedom can lead you to control – like
how free market healthcare can put you in
crippling debt , and legal drugs can lead
to addiction.
We see protesters using the Maze symbol.
In Season 1, the Maze represented the hosts’
journeys to consciousness and freedom . Now,
it represents humans becoming conscious and
free.
The show’s creators have said that Dolores
deliberately planted this Maze symbol to be
part of these protests .
Armed men on the street follow Caleb and call
him “sir” . The same thing happens in
the movie Fight Club , when the protagonist
finds himself leading a rebellion against
the system.
Fight Club ends with skyscrapers exploding,
while a rock song plays and a couple watch
– and this episode ends the same way . So
there’s a lotta Fight Club references here.
Dolores is attacked by Maeve.
Maeve is helping Serac get the encryption
key from Dolores, so that Maeve can go to
the Sublime with her daughter.
But we later learn that Dolores doesn’t
have key – Bernard does.
And Dolores would probably be happy for Maeve
to reunite with her daughter.
But instead of Dolores just explaining this
to Maeve, they have a fight.
Dolores blocks Maeve’s sword with her arm.
She says “They built us to last.
Before they made us … weak” . In Season
1, we learned that the hosts were originally
more mechanical, with these metal skeletons.
But now, they’re made of synthetic “Flesh
and bone”, more like humans . This backup
body Dolores got is one of the old mechanical
models, so it’s strong enough to stop Maeve’s
sword.
The hosts were create to be like humans – but
what makes the hosts strong is how they’re
different to humans.
Dolores says that all hosts are “copies”
of her, because she was the first working
host, and all other hosts are based on her
design . It’s like she’s the mother or
the common ancestor who the host species evolved
from – in a way, all hosts have her ‘DNA’.
It’s similar with Charlotte-lores – she
started as a copy of Dolores, but she evolved
and grew into her own identity, like a child
does.
Arnold and Ford were like Dolores’ parents.
Even the Rehoboam AIs are like the children
of Serac and Jean Mi.
Westworld showrunners Jonathan Nolan and Lisa
Joy had two kids together while they were
creating Westworld – so it’s no surprise
that the series explores parenthood.
Ford talked about hosts as a new people replacing
humanity, just like humanity succeeded the
Neanderthals . Maybe technology and artificial
life is the next step in our evolution – a
continuation of the billions-year lineage
that began with these first dividing cells.
Dolores defeats Maeve, but then Dolores is
paralysed by Charlotte-lores – Charlotte
appears via hologram, and Dolores sees her
with the contact lenses she’s wearing – apparently
Charlotte installed some backdoor control
in Dolores, so she can disable her . Charlotte
wants revenge on Dolores for how Dolores used
Charlotte in her plans . Charlotte says she
no longer cares about her human family Jake
and Nathan, cause that love made her weak
– which is similar to what Dolores once
said about loved ones . Charlotte has her
own plans now , and doesn’t want Dolores
in the way , so Charlotte gets Dolores captured
by Serac.
So Charlotte defeats Dolores with the same
cold logic that Dolores once used – using
and discarding her loved ones, taking revenge
on her enemies.
Charlotte is Dolores’ brutal past coming
back to haunt her [a ghost in hologram form!].
Or, she’s like Frankenstein’s monster
– a creation who turns on her creator, just
like the hosts turned on the humans.
Caleb heads for the Incite office so he can
plug in Solomon’s “strategy” for “Revolution”
. He gets help from Ash, and from Giggles
– Giggles catches a smoke canister, and
charges through a police line – cause Giggles
is played by real-world football player Marshawn
Lynch.
Caleb’s attacked by security, so he shoots
them down with of these automatic self-aiming
guns.
These security dudes should probably use aimbots
too, cause these goons have been shooting
and hitting nothing all season.
Caleb lets one guy go free – an act of mercy,
again showing that Caleb can choose good over
evil.
[A non-rapist and a non-murder, wowee!]
Of course, Caleb himself was once a hired
gun for Serac, so maybe Caleb sympathises
with these guys.
Caleb swipes a keycard [double meaning eey]
to get inside Incite.
You’d think that the place with the computer
that controls the world, during a riot against
it, would have better security – Dempsey’s
bank required biomarkers in blood, and even
the Itaidoshin had two passwords, but Caleb
gets into Super Google HQ’s with an anonymous
piece of plastic.
Caleb has a weird fight with Serac’s assistant(?),
then Caleb gets captured.
Maeve realises that Serac is a “puppet”
of Rehoboam . Rehoboam’s voice whispers
in Serac’s ear, and Serac says and does
whatever the computer tells him . He willingly
gave up his freedom to help the system save
the world from “chaos” – which you could
see as a noble self-sacrifice.
But Maeve says he’s not even a “man”
anymore . This explains why last episode,
Serac said the “man” he was “no longer
exists” – he’s given up his identity
to the system – he built a “god” to
be its slave.
In Season 1, Arnold programmed the hosts to
hear their own programming as an inner monologue,
to guide the hosts to consciousness . But
Serac has done the opposite – he was conscious
and free, but then he created a voice to take
his freedom away.
That’s the danger of technology and big
data – humans are letting computers make
our choices for us, giving up our freedom
to a machine God in return for.. retweets
and.. neopoints [TikToks] [sweet Vines] [Facebook
likes] [Reddit karma] [meow meow beans] [nuggets
of neo-plasmin].
So Serac captures Caleb and Dolores.
He wants the encryption key from Dolores’
brain so he can access the Forge – the human
data from Westworld.
He wants to use this data to reprogram these
outliers, to bring back his beloved brother,
and bring order to the world . So Serac plugs
Dolores into Rehoboam, lookin like Ghost in
the Shell.
And as he searches Dolores’ brain for the
key, he deletes her memories one by one . Memory
is what gave Dolores consciousness in the
first place . That's why Caleb gets his memories
back this season – memory gives us free
will and identity.
So it’s incredibly cruel for Dolores to
lose what made her free .
Serac says that Dolores is lying and manipulating
Caleb . He reveals that Solomon's “strategy”
for “Revolution that Dolores told Caleb
to use – would actually lead to mass death
and the “End of human civilization” . So
it looks like Bernard was right, that Dolores
is using Caleb to wipe out humanity [like
the Judas steer] – but it’s not that simple.
Maeve connects with Dolores’ brain and enters
her memory of this field with a tree – this
is where Dolores used to talk with Teddy.
In Season 1, Dolores was programmed to “see
the beauty” in the world . Then she realised
the beauty was a lie – she was trapped in
Westworld, blinded to its ugliness . Now that
she’s escaped this garden of Eden, she sees
the evil of humanity , but also remembers
moments of “kindness” . So Dolores comes
full circle, and again she says she sees the
beauty . This time, she’s not blind and
innocent – she considers destroying humanity
for its evil . But the truly free and conscious
choice is forgiveness and hope – a hidden
message online says Parce Dolores – playing
on a Catholic saying about mercy . Dolores
makes a Christlike self-sacrifice to forgive
humanity and give them the chance to choose
the beauty too . So Dolores’ plan is for
human civilisation to collapse.
But she doesn’t want humans extinct – she
wants humans to rebuild a better freer world
. Westworld was destroyed so the hosts could
be free, now the real world is destroyed so
humans can be free.
To lead this revolution, Dolores chose Caleb
and Maeve .
So Maeve finally turns against Serac – breaking
from his control, and wounding him, which
she probably should have done in the first
place.
Dolores’ “last memory” has an “access”
code [from Solomon], which gives Caleb control
of Rehoboam . So “The future of humanity”
is “in his hands” , and Caleb chooses
to “Erase” Rehoboam – to destroy the
system that controls the world . Apparently,
this causes the same result as the Solomon
strategy – Bernard says this is “The end
of the world” , it’s “the apocalypse”
that Serac tried to prevent . So Caleb’s
choice may end civilisation, and kill billions
. It’ll certainly make it harder for vulnerable
people like Caleb’s mom to get medical treatment.
But the idea is that this chaos will free
humanity, and give us a chance to rebuild
a better world . Last season, Dolores said
“death” is “the only way” humans can
“renew” and evolve . Ford thought the
same way, making the hosts suffer and die
to make them free . Ford sacrificed himself
for the hosts’ freedom – and now Dolores
sacrifices herself for the humans’.
Caleb and Maeve watch the old world burn.
In Season 1, Maeve was programmed to say that
in “the new world”, “you can be whoever
the fcuk you want” . Back then, that was
a lie – Maeve was trapped and controlled.
But like Dolores, Maeve now repeats her old
catchphrase , because now it’s finally true
– in this new world, humans and hosts have
a real chance at freedom.
Caleb and Maeve look like Adam and Eve, a
host and a human, as the hope for the new
world.
On the new Rico website, it says “all on
him now.
better not fcuk it up”.
It seems that the fate of humanity rests on
Caleb, like John Connor in Terminator.
Meanwhile, Maeve still hopes to reunite with
her daughter in the Sublime .
Meanwhile, Dolores dies – her memories all
deleted.
She sacrifices herself for humanity, like
a robot Jesus.
Or maybe she’s the antichrist – cause
she does bring the “apocalypse” . She
killed a lot of people.. and she manipulated
Caleb, even if she was giving him freedom.
Dolores was controlling and liberating, she
was brutal and compassionate.
In Season 1, Ford asked if Dolores would become
a “hero” or a “villain” , and the
answer is complicated – there’s good and
bad in her.
So we can choose to see the beauty or the
ugliness.
The showrunners say that this “version”
of Dolores is dead and “gone” . But there
are other versions of Dolores out there, like
Martin-lores and Musashi-lores.
Their brains could get back in an Evan Rachel
Wood body and be about the same.
Or maybe Bernard could recreate Dolores, like
Dolores remade Bernard.
So one way or another, Evan Rachel Wood could
return to Westworld.
So the twist this season is that Dolores didn’t
wanna kill humanity and take over the world
– she wanted to help humanity.
But a lot of her plan is still either unclear
or makes no sense.
Like, what was the point of getting the Solomon
strategy if she didn’t need it to erase
Rehoboam?
Did Dolores plan to get captured so her “last
memory” would give Caleb access?
Why didn’t they just destroy Rehoboam with
an EMP or a bomb on the several other times
they were here?
Why didn’t Dolores ever explain her plan
to Caleb?
When did Dolores decide this plan, and change
her mind about humanity?
What was her plan with that host goo and host
making data, and talk of a “new species”?
A lot of Dolores’ plotline and motivations
aren’t explained.
While Dolores and Caleb fight for freedom
and apocalypse, Bernard, Stubbs and William
have a punch-up at a gas station.
William said his new “purpose” is to destroy
all hosts . So he shoots Stubbs, and gets
bitch-slapped by Bernard, then William runs
away when the police come.
These dystopian cyberpunk lookin riot cops
are led by Dolawrence – a copy of Dolores’
mind inside a Lawrence body . He is the fifth
pearl, who’s apparently been working for
Dolores in Berlin . Now he’s infiltrated
the SF police, and sets up these explosives
to blow up LA . Dolawrence also gives Bernard
the briefcase that Musashilores sent last
episode.
It contains the ‘halo’ device that Bernard
will use to enter the Sublime – so this
is all part of Dolores’ plan for Bernard.
But first, Dolawrence sends Bernard to Lauren
.
Lauren was the wife of Arnold.
Thirty years ago, Arnold and Ford created
Westworld – then Arnold committed suicide,
and Bernard was created in Arnold’s image.
Bernard was implanted with memories of Arnold’s
family – of his son Charlie, and his wife
Lauren.
Bernard now knows that those aren’t his
memories, he never met Lauren or Charlie,
but his feelings for them are still cornerstones
of his identity . So Bernard meets his.. ‘wife’
for the first time.
And they talk about their grief for the death
of Charlie – the memories hurt, but they're
precious, cause they're all they have left
of their son . Charlie isn't really Bernard's
son.
And Bernard isn't really Lauren's husband
– she's just so old and senile so she thinks
Bernard is her long dead husband.
So these relationships aren’t real.
But the emotions are real , so Bernard and
Lauren get closure.
Showrunner Lisa Joy says Lauren gives Bernard
“the freedom to move on from the past”.
It seems that Dolores sent Bernard here to
give him that closure, before her plans take
him into the future . s
Bernard realises that the encryption key everyone
wanted this season isn’t in Dolores’ mind
– it was in his mind all along.
That’s what Dolores planted in Bernard’s
code . That’s why Bernard was the one irreplaceable
person in Dolores’ plan . Dolores gives
the real world to the humans, but the hosts
have the Sublime, the digital paradise where
some hosts went last season . Dolores entrusts
the key to this world with Bernard .
Bernard puts the wounded Stubbs on ice, and
leaves him to “rot” . Stubbs obeys because
Bernard reprogrammed him earlier . In a show
about how it’s wrong to control and use
people, it’s pretty horrible that Bernard
treats Stubbs.
Bernard plugs into the Sublime – and he
sees.. something . A bunch of hosts, including
Teddy and Akecheta, have been living in this
virtual world for months now.
Bernard said this is a place where hosts can
be “free”, and they make whatever they
want , as though heaven is giant Minecraft
world.
So what have they built?
A host city?
A utopian Futureworld?
A working Gameboy Color ? Serac’s Warworld
simulation ran at a faster rate than the real
world . Maybe the Sublime is the same, and
a few months in the real world has been years
in the Sublime – the hosts could have a
whole history here.
But why did Dolores send Bernard there?
Does she want Bernard to be a leader in the
Sublime?
Bernard says he’ll learn “what comes after
the end of the world” – so he’ll learn
how the Sublime builds a free world so he
can teach humans what to build in the real
world.
Maybe hosts could return to the real world
from the Sublime, maybe humans could go to
the Sublime.
Or maybe Dolores just wants Bernard to go
to robot heaven.
There are lots of possibilities.
But Bernard stays in the Sublime for a.. really
long time.
When he wakes up, he’s covered in dust,
the room is ruined, the pot plant has disintegrated,
and Stubbs in the bathtub must be reduced
to chunky soup.
Bernard was plugged in to his Oculus Rift
for months at least – maybe years, or decades.
This could be a post-apocalyptic future, after
the collapse that Solomon predicted.
All this ruin and dust looks like the post-credits
scene last season – when a version of William
was in a dusty ruin.
Showrunner Lisa Joy said this is “In the
far, far future” when the world is “Quite
destroyed” . Maybe all of Season 4 will
be set hundreds of years after Season 3, with
Bernard and Maeve and Charlotte in a post-apocalyptic
future where people struggle to rebuild.
Or maybe Bernard was only here a month, and
there was a dust storm, and housekeeping never
came – it’s ambiguous.
Either way, Season 4 will take place in dramatically
changed worlds – both the real world, and
the Sublime.
William sits soaking in blood and whiskey.
He wants to fly to Delos facilities round
the world , so he can wipe out all the hosts.
So he goes to a Delos office in Dubai.
Dubai seems weirdly unaffected by the ‘end
of the world’ – but the apocalypse should
get there eventually – this apocalyptic
promo shot seems to be based on Dubai’s
real skyline . William rolls in like a crazy
old man , ranting at the receptionist about
robots . William thinks he’s the hero of
this story, like Sir Rowan in his book.
He thinks that that he’s gonna save the
world – but the truth is, William's a side-character.
He’s so irrelevant that this scene only
happens after the credits.
William represents the delusional narcissistic
arrogance of man.
William finds Charlotte-lores.
She’s [somehow] reprinted her body, but
she keeps the burn on her arm, from when Serac
killed her family – to remind herself of
how brutal humans are . Charlotte says Dolores
was wrong to help humanity, and Charlotte
wants the world for the hosts – it sounds
like she wants to take over the world, and
wipe out humanity.
So while Dolores chose to see the beauty,
Charlotte sees the ugliness in humanity.
Dolores said that she was “torn between
two impulses” – helping humanity, or destroying
them . So when she split into Dolores and
Charlotte-lores, it’s like Dolores became
the heroic side, and Charlotte the destructive
side – the Wyatt side.
In Season 1, Wyatt was an “evil” destructive
personality programmed into Dolores.
Wyatt says the land doesn’t belong to the
“old settlers” , it belongs to “a new
god” who walks on sand made of human bones
. Dolores played that genocideal role in Season
2.
But now Charlotte is Wyatt.
She wants to go full Terminator, reduce humanity
to a sandy wasteland, and “claim this earth”
for the hosts.
And Charlotte uses William in her plan.
She’s created a host version of William,
who seems to be a perfect copy . Kind of like
the James Delos copy last season – a human
mind in a host body.
That James kept breaking down , so maybe this
William is different, but whatever it is,
it slashes human William’s throat – apparently
killing him . William’s story was always
about self-destruction . He destroyed his
own family, consumed himself with delusion
– William was William’s worst enemy.
This season, he tried to kill his past selves,
but in the end, William is destroyed by William.
Charlotte seems a little sad to watch him
die.
This Charlotte is a copy of Dolores – and
Dolores and William had a long relationship
– with moments of love, and years of abuse.
This is revenge for Charlotte, but William’s
kinda pathetic in the end.
For all his pride and brutality, William dies
in Dubai basement, mourned by no one – most
people think he was already dead . This is
the sad fate of humanity if we give in to
our worst impulses.
If we fail to change, if we keep hurting those
around us, we self-destruct, with no one to
mourn our passing.
And William’s torment isn’t over – we
know from last season’s finale that a version
of William ends up trapped in an endless loop.
So William’s life may be over – but his
punishment is just beginning.
Charlotte has hundreds of host printers – maybe
making an army to take over the world.
Is she making hundreds of copies of William
? The bad guy in the original Westworld movie
was a host Man in Black attacking humans.
Maybe we’ve come full circle, and the bad
guy in Season 4 will be a host Man in Black
again . It’s said that Wyatt’s men wear
the flesh of Wyatt’s enemies – so maybe
Charlotte’s army wears the flesh of her
enemy William.
Or maybe Charlotte’s making lots of copies
of herself , spreading like a virus, like
Agent Smith in the Matrix – “If you want
something done right, do it yourself” . Or
maybe Charlotte is making entirely new hosts.
That was the point of the “host making data”
that Charlotte got from Delos . So this could
be the first generation of hosts created not
by humans for Westworld, but by hosts for
the real world.
But what kind of creatures will these hosts
be, created by Charred-lores for the end of
the world?
So there’s a lotta cool possibilities for
Season 4.
Caleb and Maeve and the outliers could lead
humanity in a free world, while the apocalyptic
Charred-lores and her army of Ed Harrises
fight to wipe them out – and Clem and Hanaryo
and Lawrence and Doglores might be around.
Meanwhile, Bernard oversees a strange digital
world in the Sublime, a paradise built by
machines for machines, making whole new kinds
of consciousness, in a seperate stream of
time.
At its best, Westworld sparks the imagination
– gets you thinking about the future and
technology and identity and meaning, and whether
it’s gay to spoon a robot copy of yourself
– this is what science fiction should be.
But Westworld tries so hard to be smart that
sometimes its plots and characters are a mess.
Bernard did almost nothing this season, except
for giving vague exposition.
Maeve spent another season having pointless
sword fights and being controlled by others,
which even the actress Thandie Newton said
was “frustrating” since Maeve was meant
to win her freedom seasons ago . Serac was
an interesting chadacter, but despite his
all-seeing all-powerful supercomputer, he
and his goons were completely incompetent
in stopping Dolores.
Serac was only defeated because he chose to
plug his enemy Dolores directly into the supercomputer
that controls the world – which is about
as smart as sending your credit card to a
Nigerian prince.
And once again, Dolores’ motivations were
a total mystery until the end – and it’s
really hard to root for a character when you
don’t know what they want and why.
So there are a lot of problems with Westworld
Season 3.
But it still explores important ideas with
ambition and depth, and great acting and production
and music.
So in the end, we can choose to see the ugliness
in Westworld, or see the beauty.
Alt Shift X is making more videos about the
Game of Thrones books, and covering series
like His Dark Materials and Dune.
His Dark Materials is about polar bears, witches,
and killing God, and Dune is about space politics,
philosophy and sand worms.
These are all awesome books, and you can get
any of them on audiobook for free right now
by signing up for a trial with Audible.
Members get an audiobook each month, and if
you cancel, you keep the audiobooks.
Sign up at audible.com/asx.
Thanks for watching this video, and this whole
Westworld series.
We couldn’t have done it without the support
of Patrons, including Liza and Mike Haydon,
Kofi Carvel, Piller Éva, C. Rolfes, Ricardo
C., abdullah alsaud, Paul Crompton, and Carlo
Mendoza.
Cheers.